دبي مدينة تم بناؤها لإبهار
الأفق المستقبلي ووعدها
برفاهية منقطعة النظير أصبحت
ترمز إلى مثال البذخ ولكن وراء
ناطحات السحاب الشاهقة هناك ما هو أكثر من
هذه المدينة مما تراه العين
[الموسيقى
] تنوع الطعام المعروض هو
انعكاس  تراث المدينة
وتنوعها الثقافي لا تزال دبي تحب
احتلال عناوين الأخبار وهي مدينة
التفوق ولكن لا أعتقد أنها
بالضرورة جوهر الانقسام على الرغم من
أن المطبخ هنا متنوع ومتعدد
الأوجه ، فمن المحتمل أن يكون أحد
الوجهات القليلة في العالم حيث
لن يكون المطبخ الذي تذهب إليه من المأكولات المحلية
الآن ، وهذا لا يعني أن
النكهات الإماراتية والشرق أوسطية الأوسع ليست
ممثلة هنا ، ولكن أيضًا
كل المأكولات الأخرى في جميع أنحاء العالم
وهذا يرجع جزئيًا إلى
موقعه الذي يربط بين الشرق و  غربًا ولكن أيضًا
بسبب تعدد الثقافات السكانية
التي لدينا هنا
دبي ، فهي مدينة ديناميكية
للغاية ، ولا يزال مشهد الطهي هنا هادئًا  شابًا
نظرًا لأن الإمارات العربية المتحدة دولة شابة
ولكنها تتطور بسرعة ، فهي سوق صعبة
ولدينا الكثير من المطاعم هنا ،
يقول البعض إنه ربما يصل عدد المطاعم إلى 16000 بالنسبة
لسكان بهذا الحجم ، يجب
أن يكون لديك حقًا شيء خاص للحفاظ على عودة الناس
إلى  لا يزال المنتجع الوحيد في
مطاعم جزيرة النخلة التي يصنعها الإنسان من صنع الإنسان
يجتهد للقيام بذلك فقط لأن
القوة الإبداعية هي الشيف المقيم في باريس يانيك ألين
أو عندما أتيت إلى دبي ، فأنا
فقط مع فريقي أحب أن أطهو الطعام.
هناك وظيفتي التي أحب تحريك المقالي التي
أحب وضع الإسكالوب فيها كما تعلمون في
برجر أحب أن الله يعلم أن
شغفه بالطبخ الفرنسي يمتد إلى
أكثر من عشرة مطاعم
حول العالم بدأت رحلته الطهوية إلى
الإمارات العربية المتحدة تقريبًا
قبل عقد من الزمان ، كان المطعم عنصرًا
أساسيًا دائمًا في مشهد الطهي في دبي
منذ أن أصبحت طاهيًا
ورائد أعمال أيضًا عندما تنشئ
مطعمًا مثل الطفل الذي يجب أن ينمو
في بداية الإقامة يعني سيم  ple
table المشكلة هي أن عملائك لا يريدون
منك شيئًا بسيطًا يريدون
شيئًا جديدًا يريدون شيئًا جديدًا إذا
كانوا يريدون شيئًا رائعًا لذلك
ذهبنا في هذا الاتجاه وأحاول أن
أكون أفضل تخمين من في دبي أعتقد ما
كانت تفعله الشيف ألينا  صحيح أنه
يتمسك بأسلحته ، فهو يتأكد من
أنه يقدم نفس المعايير
هنا كما لو كان في باريس
يانيك وكل هؤلاء الطهاة ذوي الأسماء الكبيرة
الذين يأتون إلى هنا ، أعتقد أنهم يقدمون
الإلهام لحقيقة أنهم  إعادة المجيء إلى
هنا لافتتاح مطعم
هنا يظهر إيمانكم بالسوق
[موسيقى]